Melania and Ivanka Trump played visible
roles in the first leg of president
Trump's nine-day trip to the Middle East
in Europe the first lady and the
president's oldest daughter attended
events in Saudi Arabia highlighting new
freedoms for women in that socially
conservative country Marga Brennan is
with the president in Jerusalem where
all three trumps arrived a few hours ago
Margaret good morning good morning well
president Trump has made it a policy not
to publicly lecture on human rights but
first lady Melania and Ivanka Trump both
celebrated women's empowerment in Saudi
Arabia where women were recently granted
more freedoms including the right to
enroll at university and to open a bank
account without requiring a man's
permission Ivanka Trump tried to fill
her father's shoes on Sunday standing in
for him at a social media event in Saudi
Arabia social media is an incredibly
powerful tool on the sidelines of the
presidential visit both Ivanka and First
Lady Melania Trump attended events
focused on female empowerment in a
country where gender segregation still
exists the first lady visited a GE call
center staffed entirely by women and
Ivanka posted this image of an economic
focused event with women leaders where
both the Kingdom and the United Arab
Emirates pledged 100 million dollars to
a proposed world bank women's
empowerment fund following the tradition
of past first ladies mrs. Trump did not
cover her hair on the trip
neither did Ivanka something mr. Trump
criticized Michelle Obama for not doing
in 2015 the first lady was by President
Trump's side at nearly all of his public
events and was personally welcomed by
Saudi King Salman
the two most prominent women in
president Trump's life also sat behind
him as he delivered an address to
leaders of more than 50 Muslim majority
countries saying that he hoped for a
bright future for both men and women
when young Muslim men and women should
have the chance to build a new era of
prosperity for themselves it has to be
done and we have to let them do it while
Ivanka Trump praised what she called
progress in Saudi Arabia the US State
Department says there is still pervasive
gender discrimination in that kingdom
gale they say women are not driving
there thank you very much Margaret